with every major world event
we see an impact on office design
[Music]
the offices workers left aren't the ones
many will return to
for those who return it all we have been
through crises before
whether that was 911 superstorm sandy
where you really
have to take a step back and move with a
sense of urgency
thermal scanners plexiglas shields and
one-way hallways are now part of the
workplace
as concerns about coronavirus spread
have forced firms to retrofit spaces to
bring workers back
these modifications are only a start
innovation
comes out of moments like the ones we're
in right now
offices are also being redesigned and
reimagined for an uncertain future
where health is the focus even if covet
19 is no longer a threat
so what's changed in offices open now
and how will the future office look
and function differently
let's start with the retrofit
at its office in midtown manhattan rxr
realty employees are back at work
with modifications so our objective is
to use
the tools and technologies that we
implemented to make
the new abnormal at the office feel as
normal as possible
employees now start their days by
opening up the company's mobile app to
answer a series of health questions
once cleared they will get a green
allowing them to enter the 32-story
building which the real estate firm owns
inside thermal cameras take employees
temperatures as they walk through the
lobby
the goal is not to let people not come
to work but to really ensure that
they're not coming in sick
to potentially make other people sick in
the building i will say that there's no
such thing as no risk
and i think there has to be a good
reason to bring people back
rxr owns more than 25 million square
feet of office space
we want to test out a lot of what we put
in place for ourselves to make sure that
it works
as our tenants come back to work some of
the things they're testing
touchless entry at turn styles that
automatically call elevators that take
workers to their floor
rotation staffing that keeps floors at
less than 50 capacity
plexiglas dividers between workstations
reduced seating in conference rooms and
small social distancing devices
employees wear if i'm within six feet of
someone else
this will vibrate and go off same thing
for that person
it also serves as a contact tracer so
that if someone does get sick
we can then determine who is around that
person and make sure that we can notify
them
many of these solutions are aimed at
preventing transmission through large
droplets or sheared surfaces
but the virus can also transmit via
smaller aerosolized droplets
so this is trickier to deal with in
buildings
the typical office building today we
heat and cool the space with air
this means that we spend a lot of energy
heating and cooling that air
and we don't want to just exhaust the
used air so we recirculate a portion of
it
meaning that if occupants introduce
pathogens into that air
they can remain airborne one way of
mitigating this is by increasing the
building's intake of natural air which
is something rxr is doing
the company is also replacing that air
more often
another way is through filtration of
that recirculated air
some buildings are upgrading to filters
that can catch smaller particles such as
the merv 13 filters rxr uses
but existing air systems limit exactly
which filters buildings can use
another strategy is ultraviolet
germicidal irradiation
which means that you have light fixtures
and instead of outputting visible light
it's
ultraviolet light that can inactivate
the sars kobe 2 virus these retrofits of
course
cost money rxr said it spent millions of
dollars across all of its properties to
make these changes
and some of the extremes might shed away
once we have a
vaccine and we can you know move more
freely around but some of it's going to
stay because people say you know what
i'm more sensitive about my health and
wellness
[Music]
plans for gensler's new office in miami
were set in february
then as the coronavirus took hold in
march that design as it
stood at that point of time no longer
worked
so carlos valera the architecture firm's
managing director in miami began the
redesign
starting by identifying what potential
problems existed in the original plans
here we see an area in which there is
a row of workstations that align with
what we might have done prior to the
pandemic in which you would see a lot of
density
prior to the pandemic dense offices were
the trend average square footage per
employee had decreased from 211 square
feet in 2009
to 194 at the end of 2017.
we see here what we had conceived as a
hospitality lounge
that type of design solution is no
longer possible
with the pain points identified valera
and his team set out to design an office
that would be ready for both pre-vaccine
and post-vaccine futures
they thinking behind this new reimagined
workplace is really more about
experimentation one of the ideas gensler
is testing
separating the office into zones clients
and employees enter separately
we have here what we're referring as a
sanitation room
we also have created an isolation room
in case again that someone is not
feeling well
the two zones will also have separate
ventilation systems to help limit
potential exposure
and by putting these reconfigurable
boosts into the client zone
gensler is also creating a space for
meetings outside of the main office
that flexibility extends to the employee
space as well
where valera has removed many of the
fixed elements
we have workstations that have the
option to be reconfigured
into a two-person pot three-person pot
four-person pot
but also the workstation itself can move
around
and be set in a way that you're not
facing each other
the firm is using a spatial intelligence
tool called graph to map out distancing
scenarios it may need during the
pandemic
it could also help determine where more
seats are needed after a vaccine
so what you see in this plan is kind of
what a phase one
high risk transmission scenario is but
also we are
tooling the space in a way that we can
densify is needed but how much is still
unclear
global workplace analytics estimates we
will see 25 to 30 percent of the
workforce working at home
multiple days a week by the end of 2021.
that will not only impact density but
also change workers relationship to the
office itself
i think that in some cases we're
realizing that we don't need the office
as much as we thought we did i also
think
that we're realizing how much we missed
the office a june survey of corporate
leaders found that in the future
82 plan to allow remote working at least
some of the time
valera calls this the hybrid model when
you're working from home
some of those spaces could be used for
something else maybe the idea of
large expanses of desk space and a small
cafe
might be flipped and maybe we end up
with more of a cafe
and less desk space in a hybrid model
focused work could be done at home
offices could be more flexible spaces
used for meeting
i think the whole idea of the office
might even become more flexible
so maybe we might see a new type of
business pop-up that's kind of a
restaurant
with individual conference rooms
of course these solutions only work for
firms that can keep workers at home at
least some of the time
the national bureau of economic research
found about 37 percent of u.s workers
could plausibly do their jobs from home
so experts say what workers will most
likely see in the future are some of the
smaller changes aimed at keeping
occupants safe
including touchless tech more access to
outdoor space and better ventilation
inside
now as you think about the workplace
you've got to think what would have been
five
ten years from now and start
incorporating that today
as for larger design changes it's still
too early to know
if we build for flexibility to explore
what works and what doesn't work
the process is going to teach us
what the future of workplace should be